[Music]
we got another question from twitter
daniel has a question for us
have you done any work around minimalism
and education for children well sort of
we are working on this thing right now
uh with the folks from ramsey solutions
we
are
trying to well promote financial
literacy because i think it's one of the
biggest problems that we have
is we go to school we're taught to build
a credit score to go into debt as soon
as you turn 18 by getting six figures or
five figures worth of college loans
and all of a sudden before we know it we
turn around we're 30 years old with six
figures worth of debt so the average
american household that is indebted has
ninety seven thousand seven hundred and
seventy five dollars in debt
and so what is that it's credit card
debt it is automobile debt
this school debt that's non-mortgage
debt by the way
so
we're facing six figures worth of debt
before we even start living our lives
and then it keeps us from what living
our lives because now i feel tethered to
this lifestyle right and so ryan and i
we've been working with the folks at
ramsey solutions to provide well
financial literacy training for every
high school student and every middle
school student in dayton ohio so a quick
plug for that i don't get any money for
this but you can help contribute 25
bucks gives curriculum to one middle
school student 45 bucks to a high school
student the minimalists.com education if
you're interested so that's my plug for
helping some kids out so they're not
borrowing from their future because
ultimately that's what we're talking
about
i don't think
and we may differ on this quite a bit
tk's works with a lot of students i
don't think we have anything to teach
our kids
and and here's what i mean by that i
want to be get really specific here i
think that minimalism is sort of the
natural state for human beings we've
complected our lives we've added all
this complexity to our lives through
expectations through consumerism through
careers through career paths through
whatever material goods we think we
should have
and just societal constructs basically
saying here's what you're going to do
and then you're going to be happy right
and so i want to help my daughter avoid
those things
but i don't have anything to teach her
in the sense like i never taught her how
to bend her elbow
she just figured that out right
you create the environment so that she
can do these things i never taught her
how to um
eat food i didn't teach her how to get
hungry
no that that happens that appears on its
own now of course i'm not saying we
don't add
boundaries for our kids we certainly
have to i can't say when she was three
years old you can't just go play out in
traffic good luck with that no there are
boundaries that we set for our kids but
in terms of teaching i think it has much
more to do with setting up the
environment now we don't send ella to
public school anymore just because i
found that that
that route was poisonous
and and so we've removed her from from
that system that wasn't working well for
her
and and so well why it wasn't working
well because in that environment she was
not thriving her personally not every
kid but her person she was not thriving
so removing her from environments that
in which she doesn't thrive it doesn't
mean we remove all the obstacles i'm not
going to bubble wrap her world in fact
it's the opposite of that
yeah you can climb a tree as long as i
don't have to lift you into it you can
climb as high as you want
because you'll figure out how to get
down if you climbed it yourself
yeah
socrates
saw education
not as the process of imparting that
which is not known into the heart and
mind of the student but rather
unearthing what already exists in that
person's soul helping them recollect
what they always knew
sometimes we know things but then we get
away from what we know because of
societal pressure because of different
kinds of influences that result in us
mistrusting ourselves or losing that
self-love and so the best educators are
the ones that help you
recall
what you natively know it's sort of like
teaching a balloon how to float you just
can't do that a balloon doesn't need you
to teach it how to float
however if someone took a string and
tied a stone to that balloon you'll find
that the balloon actually is capable of
sinking and your job as the educator is
to come along and cut that string to
remove the stones that hold the balloon
back from doing what it is part of its
nature to do and so i believe that
students are capable of thinking for
themselves they're capable of more great
things than they could possibly imagine
but they're weighed down by the stones
of so many self-defeating fallacies that
they've picked up already at a very
young age and so one of the ways i go
into classrooms and teach this as the
education director at fee
is
i help students make that shift from the
consumer mindset to the creator mindset
because when you think about all the
good things in life
you can't consume them you can't consume
happiness you can't consume love
you can't consume fulfillment you have
to create happiness you have to create
fulfillment you have to create an
amazing career you have to create a
wonderful lifestyle but consumption
isn't bad it's a part of being human we
have to take the resources of the earth
and use them to meet our needs but
consumption is only fulfilling when it's
contextualized by a life of creativity
which is why when you consume without
creating you tend to be more depressed
and you tend to lack the joy that comes
from being able to create wealth and so
what i do is when i talk with students i
say look consuming is a part of life but
what becomes of the possibilities of
your life when you think of yourself as
someone more than just you know wanting
that pair of shoes do you know that the
power exists in you to create something
just like that or maybe even better than
that that another person can put on
their feet and their feet can feel
really good and they say wow this is the
best pair of shoes i ever had like do
you know that that potential exists
within you and maybe it's not shoes
maybe it's music maybe it's fashion
maybe it's something completely
different
your soul knows what that is my job is
to remove the stones that keep what is
within you from coming to the surface
and i believe that's really the essence
of what this is all about
yeah i mean i agree with but
i read somewhere the idea that knowledge
is like
that information we seem to think that
uh
getting gaining information is the way
to be
when all it really does is sort of uh
not to keep harping on the idea but it
it gives us expectations and rigidity in
the way that we are instead of uh
knowledge through experience and and
growth in that way of becoming who we
actually are
um being kind of pumped
full of
information we in the information age
that we live in
it's all empty calories you know because
really the thing is
uh knowledge comes from experience and
from learning and then that's really
what we're looking for so as teachers i
feel like it's my job as as a parent to
be the best to allow my kid to become
the best she that she is
you know the and truly like it's it's
that's my whole goal like you said to
remove anything to try and help her
remove any obstacles that get in the way
of her fulfilling who she is
yeah hey look i'm gonna put this out
there josh i don't know if i'll get in
trouble but i will come to your high
school for free and i'll talk about this
if we can make it work right like get as
many people together as you can so we
can make it count as opposed to like me
trying to hit up 100 high schools to
talk to a handful of people each time
but if you can get together 100 plus
people high school students and you want
me to talk about this i don't know if
i'm getting in trouble for this on my
first day on the minimalist but i will
come in there myself and i'll talk about
some of these things for free i won't
charge you a dime just send an email
podcast.minimalists.com mallory will
will get that over to us for sure
[Music]
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
or click the link in the description
your support keeps our podcast and
youtube channel 100
advertisement free